تحاول القوات الأوكرانية يائسة
الصمود في وجه موجات
الهجمات الروسية، حيث أصبحت الجبهة الشرقية
مركزًا لغزو فلاديمير بوتين
الوحشي
لأوكرانيا، وتقول قوات الخطوط الأمامية التي تحدثت إلى شبكة CNN إنها
تستطيع الصمود في وجه الهجوم ولكن
فقط إذا استمرت في الحصول على الأسلحة
من أوكرانيا.
الولايات المتحدة بالطبع لن تتراجع، كما
يقول الجندي، لكننا لن ننتصر حقًا
بدون الدعم من الولايات
المتحدة. من الصعب تحقيق المكاسب في
شتاء أوروبا الشرقية القاسي، حيث تظل جميع الخطوط الأمامية تقريبًا ثابتة
على الرغم من المعارك الصعبة.
الرئيس الأوكراني فلاديمير
زينسكي يزور مركز قيادة ويطلب من
قواته مواصلة القتال،
أتوسل إليكم للفوز لتكونوا أقوياء، لا
تضيعوا مبادرتكم، قال زينسكي، لكن
الرئيس الأوكراني يتعامل أيضًا مع
النتائج القاتمة المتزايدة
للهجمات الروسية أثناء زيارته
لمستشفى للأطفال  علاج مبتوري
الأطراف وعيادة عسكرية حيث
شكر زيلينسكي الجنود الذين يعانون من ندوب المعركة على
خدمتهم في يوم القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية،
النصر قادم، وما هو البديل
الآخر الذي
نعرفه جميعًا أنه
لا يمكن أن يكون هناك بديل، ولكن على الرغم من الخسائر الهائلة في ساحة المعركة، فإن
الروس ليسوا كذلك
التراجع، وبينما تحاول الولايات المتحدة عزل
فلاديمير بوتين
دوليًا،
يقوم بعض أهم حلفاء أمريكا في الشرق الأوسط ببسط
السجادة الحمراء للزعيم
الروسي
[موسيقى]
لم تفرض كل من المملكة العربية السعودية والإمارات العربية المتحدة عقوبات على روسيا
بسبب الحرب.  في أوكرانيا وتظلون
شركاء مهمين للكرملين في
أسواق النفط والغاز العالمية اليوم بفضل موقفكم
وصلت علاقاتنا إلى
مستوى عالٍ غير مسبوق قال بوتين في
الإمارات العربية المتحدة رسالة بوتين إلى الولايات المتحدة
وحلفائها روسيا لن تكون
معزولة حتى في ظل ظروف ثقيلة  العقوبات
اقتصاده واقف على قدميه وصندوقه الحربي
ممتلئ لمواصلة هجومه على
أوكرانيا وآرون للمرة الأولى
تتهم الولايات المتحدة الآن أربعة جنود روس
غائبين
بارتكاب جرائم حرب ضد مواطن أمريكي
يعيش في أوكرانيا، لائحة اتهام تم الكشف عنها
اليوم تتهم الروس الأربعة
باحتجاز وتعذيب أمريكي بشكل غير قانوني
عندما غزوا بلدة
ميلوفا في جنوب أوكرانيا في أبريل من
العام الماضي.